bill simmons ringer dot-com the BS
podcast he's got the Malcolm Gladwell in
Judd Apatow his guest this week bill
how's morale as we're out for self
expander for life
um how about build a Celtic fan right
now hell's morale I went into a funk
yesterday I got bummed out about Lonzo
ball because you know the Celtics had
the first pick and then they trade down
the three there's no chance at lanza
they weren't going to take Lonzo at one
I had never really thought about Alonso
at one and then yesterday I was
listening to the radio and I started
thinking about I'm like man what if this
guy is like you know the cross between
Ricky Rubio and Magic Johnson and Jason
Kidd is just like the most fun NBA
player and the Celtics just passed on
him and took another small forward when
we have nine small forwards but I'm out
of it now now I'm happy I'm excited for
Jason Tatum he's going to be the next
Paul Pierce we needed some scoring so
I'm back in but I did go on a funk well
what was it about yesterday that you
thought about with Lonzo ball that oh my
gosh we're passing up this transcendent
basketball player it was like because
well you know because you put you play
do you still plan to retire I just shoot
you just shoot yeah eventually we all
turn in a stretch force but I just think
you so much fun to watch and it's going
to depend on what team he goes on and it
was teammates are what style they play
and it's probably like a 50% chance
he'll never hit the ceiling of what he
could be on the right team but you know
he I watched it with bird I grew up
obviously in Massachusetts and the
effect that bird had on the Celtics we
have somebody who's such a great passer
just becomes contagious to everyone else
on the team and by the mid-80s Kevin
McHale story no-look passes that guy was
a black hole so it just rarely happens
where you have these guys that come in
and their style of play actually
inspects everybody else and that's the
thing you know the Lakers I don't want
them to get LeBron out of watch rather
I've seen them just build this young
really fun team around
Lonzo and see where that went now it's
like
they're gonna take lines though they're
going to put LeBron and Paul George and
they're gonna try to create this super
team right away Alonzo is just going to
be thrown into that I don't think that's
a good situation for him
you think LeBron ends up with the Lakers
not the Clippers yeah I thought so for a
couple weeks that was all everyone was
talking about the finals and then two
weeks ago in the ringer Kevin O'Connor
and I we finally just did a podcast
because I I was like I want to get in
front of this I think this feels like
this is going to be the story you know
and when he went to Cleveland in 2014 it
really did seem like he was going back
for good and now you kind of look back
at it and you think well if he was going
back for good they probably would have
kept Wiggins they wouldn't have had this
urgency to be good right away and spend
all this money and try to contend
immediately versus actually trying to
build something for the rest of the
decade and now it just seems it feels a
touch disingenuous right because you go
back and read that 2014 Sports
Illustrated piece on that so it's like
I'm coming home I have a chance to make
a huge impact this is where I belong and
if he goes to LA in a year what does
that mean I mean I think these guy I've
really changed my mind and my opinion on
this stuff over the years about I think
people like us spend too much time to
you know deciding what's best for other
people whether it's LeBron go to Miami I
was so mad when the brown went to Miami
and now seven years later it's like I
wanted to live in South Beach like
whatever but I do feel like you know all
the rhetoric and everything he said in
2014 if he then goes to LA I don't know
how I'd feel about that if I was a
Cavalier sir yeah he brought you one
title but it felt like that was a bigger
move than just I'm coming back to win
one title and then we're good we're even
what do you do - we're good what do you
want to do if your Dan Gilbert right now
if you know or you feel LeBron is going
to leave I would have traded him this
summer I think that was like the
ballsiest move of all you meet like
because clearly they don't like each
other and LeBron going back there in
2014 it was it was very
kind of walkabout eggshells the
relationship between the two of them and
they met and the whole thing but then
you know LeBron gave this I forget where
it was it was the the thing with the
shop I think when he was with dream on
that thing they taped a while ago yeah
and he talked about the owner in a never
called him by his name he talked about
how when when he was thinking about
going back his mom and his friends like
didn't want him to go back to Cleveland
they were still mad at the owner and he
part of me wonder is that this is a way
bigger power struggle than we realized
she goes back get stand over to just
been crazy amounts of money on the team
and now he's going to ditch them again
in a year if that happens so if I'm Dan
Gilbert and this is this is like
basically a power-play standoff the best
way to win that when we're going to
destroy it in the summer I don't think
anybody would have the balls to do that
but if you're looking for how do you
protect this team for the next ten years
the worst case there would be trading
Kevin loves doing this quick hit Paul
George trade and then a year from now
you just have Kyrie Irving okay how is
that a good situation and that doesn't
mean Kyrie is going to want to stay
either if that's how he's going to way
he'll be on the first train out of there
so I don't know I think every you know
people have made this point before and I
and this week and I agree with it to
some degree that I think the Warriors
have they were so good and they seemed
so invincible that it seems to have
thrown the NBA into just complete flex
you know it's really like I said
yesterday on my podcast that it's like
the the league is like a snow globe and
the words just shook the snow globe and
just everything's in chaos right now
every pretty much every team has done
something major we were joking in the
office history we're like who are the
most bummed out teams who are the teams
that are just not involved with this
week the fan bases that all this stuff's
happening and you know you're rooting
for a team that's just not involved and
we and one of the things we we said with
Charlotte it's like ah imagine being a
Charlotte fan you're just not involved
asleep then they go
trade for Dwight Howard it's like
everything every team is involved in
some way and just does not stop chaos
and it's you know the this decade I
think we're going to remember it as the
decade when the NBA became 11 months for
it to season ends then the draft free
agency and by the time we come up for
air it's like July 28th summer league
it's it's it's so different than what we
grew up with I think he's Bill Simmons
the ringer calm the BS podcast Malcolm
Gladwell and Judd Apatow his guest this
week would you think of the Laker Celtic
34:30 did not watch it really about that
yeah my choice didn't watch it I I mean
there's been three different Celtics
Lakers type documentaries already so I
mean it's on my DVR at some point I'll
get to five hours seems excessive it's
just I you know I think with thirty four
thirty now they look at the time slap
more than what the right length or
something is so five hours just seems
wrong so at some point I'll get to I'm
shocked that you didn't want you I tell
me what one piece of that documentary
that I haven't seen already I thought I
thought that well yeah being a hardcore
fan but I thought that there was of it I
was I lived through it yeah yeah I
caught watching I still watched it again
I I don't know I guess it's just it it I
think what it did it gave me a refresher
of what a real rivalry is we're trying
to make Cleveland Golden State a rivalry
it's not not in the center of what a
rivalry is I mean those were two great
teams great you know you had everything
that you wanted in a Hollywood script if
you've got black-white west coast East
Coast you know the plotting white guys
Union yet Showtime you had drama the
coach I mean there was just so much
involved in it and I just love the way
it you know how they played the game and
how many Hall of Famers were out there
one time so when you had it was like a
twenty one or twenty three team League
plant I wrote I remember ready and calm
like 1213 years ago about this about you
know if if you had the 30 team League in
1984 Kevin McHale's like on the
Mavericks you know is just it would have
been impossible to have that many good
guys on the same team and that's why I
like what the Warriors Cavs
you know people it was weird
people reacted to that Finals in a way
that I didn't expect
I thought the level of basketball was
out of control I just loved it I know
that in five games I know the words are
you know pretty invincible probably
could have swept if Cleveland didn't get
hot but I went to Game one and I went to
Game three in Game five and I just
thought the level of basketball was as
high as I've ever seen and I really
thought the team's brought the best out
of each other you know that was the best
Durant's ever played you know that was
the best Kyrie has ever played that was
the best Steph Curry has ever played it
was the best offensively that I think
LeBron has ever played you know when you
think of it that way of the top four
guys in the series you know one of whom
is the third best player of all time I
think Duran has a chance to be the third
or fourth best forward of all time Steph
is the greatest shooter of all time
Kyrie is in my opinion the best
offensive guard I've ever seen six three
another like in terms of his shot making
I've never seen any guard be able to
make more types of shots than him a has
the ringer done this have you done done
this week we brought up this topic bill
Livingston from the Cleveland Plain
Dealer said Kyrie was the greatest below
the rim finisher that he's ever seen
have ya having ever done a list of below
the rim finishers in NBA history I've
never had that I mean you know tiny
Archibald when I was growing up was like
if you did a championship belt for it he
had it for a while Kevin Johnson I think
was was up there but the thing with
Kyrie I'd Kevin Durant on my podcast
last week and he was saying he was just
raving about Kyrie and then somehow I
turned into
one of those dumb sports media stories
or because he mentioned how I was saying
that I thought Kyrie was better than
Ireson because he can make more shots
and he's more efficient and he's just
you know it's evolution he's 15 years
later he's just a better offensive
leader Iverson was and he agreed and he
was talking about how he's never seen he
can't believe nobody blocks his shot
ever Kyrie in for what you just said
he's always below the rim but he never
gets a shot blocked
I think he's incredible and it would be
interesting to see if he had his own
team I don't think he was ready for it
three four years ago but let's say
LeBron goes to Lakers Kyrie is a free
agent he go somewhere could he be the
best guy on a championship team I'm not
sure because he really is a one-on-one
player he's not somebody that makes his
teammates better true but he's the best
version of a one-on-one player at that
position I've ever seen you know so I
don't know what I don't know what that
means is that 45 wins could you win a
title that way I guess so it depends who
they built the team around them so how
are you doing are you personally you
good I'm doing great
yeah yes and it's been a really really
fun 2017 trying to build a multimedia
business especially after you know get
an experience with it with Grant land
and then kind of using the experience we
had with that but then all the different
opportunities you have with with new
media and just where stuff's going and
how people consume the internet and how
different things are in a lot of ways
and then they were six years ago it's
been pretty cool but you know to me
those goes back and I'm sure you agree
with this if you have people that you
work with that you like working with
every day is a good day you know and
it's that's what we have that's what we
built
how much you know he likes like if I
feel that I'll let you know when I can
make your guys better working for you
right now are cringing
and so my it's true though if you and we
you and I have talked about this a lot
because you know we're in works
situations once upon a time that you
know you start to feel like you just
angry for no reason you know and you're
just mad and you just and when you wake
up that way it really does infect your
day well you get mad at yourself too
because you put yourself in a position I
mean there's a lot of things that are
involved in it but you're right like
you're you're angry and then you have to
be angry at yourself yeah the best
situation if you're a creative person I
think is to be around people that you
like working with and to like what
you're doing you know and I think if you
can do both of those things you're
having a pretty good
you're having a pretty good time so you
know we had I've had touches of it I've
had stretches where I had both and now
we're in another stretch where it's like
I just like the people I work with I
like what I'm doing what's good do a
touch base with you again and enjoy the
draft it should be fun
thank you can't wait to see what the
Celtics do I have my fear is that
they're going to trade down again it is
going to be like a Belichick thing
Rivers is just by the time this is over
we have the 27th pick and nine future
picks thank you Bill
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience